-Welcome back to the show.
It is so great to see you.
-Oh! It's all been on Zoom,
and it's finally real.
-It's real! You're really real!
-Oh, you're real!
-Oh, I'm so excited.
I want to talk to you
about so many things.
Last time, I think, we talked,
you were just engaged.
-Yes.
-But now you're married.
-Now I'm married.
-Yeah, you did --
Buddy, congratulations.
-Thank you. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm so happy for you.
-Thank you.
-How was the wedding?
How was everything?
-It's -- He's backstage,
so it's going really well.
-Yeah, yeah.
-He's here.
-Yeah. Was it as planned?
Everything went according to
plan with the wedding?
-Yeah, everything
went according to plan.
And we were planning it
while shooting "Windfall."
So that was --
It was a lot on our plate.
-I mean, I've been
seeing you everywhere,
because "Emily in Paris" --
You know I'm a fan.
-Thank you.
-So, that's when we
first had -- Yeah.
-Thank you.
-Let me just tell you something.
It's one of the
top-five shows on Netflix --
in over 90 countries,
by the way.
-Crazy.
-Isn't that wild?
-That's the magic of
Netflix, though.
It's in so many countries
around the world, yeah,
and you're like, "I didn't even
know that they would be
interested in the show in,"
you know, X, Y, and Z.
-It just got picked up for
a third and fourth season,
by the way.
-Yeah. Thank you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Double whammy!
-We're so excited.
We're so excited to come back.
-Well done.
-Thank you.
-That's hard work on your part.
-People are petitioning
online to have it --
Emily be in different cities.
-I mean, honestly, I would go
all over the world with it,
if I could.
But the one thing is like,
I just want to go to
streets where
you can wear flats,
because wearing heels -- I mean,
you wouldn't think how painful
that can be in Paris.
I actually literally went to
a podiatrist every week
to fix my feet because I was
wearing heels all the time --
-'Cause it's
cobblestone everywhere.
-Everywhere. Everywhere.
And I had to have, like, insoles
made for every pair of shoes.
-Oh, my gosh.
-I'm not kidding.
-You're like, "Let's do a season
where Emily
just has to wear sneakers."
-Yeah, "Emily in Flats."
That's exactly right.
-Like, why not?
-Why not?
But everyone's getting into it.
Everyone wants to get involved.
I'm sure you saw Peyton Manning
on "Weekend Update" on
"Saturday Night Live"
a couple weeks ago.
-That was crazy.
That was so absurd.
When I saw -- My phone has never
blown up more.
-How fun --
-It was so cool!
-He's one of the funniest,
nicest guys, too.
-Is he?
-Oh, he's the greatest, yeah.
And just goes with the thing and
sees where he can go with it.
And I thought that was
perfect delivery.
-But I just want to know,
like, is he a fan?
Like, is he really a fan?
-I think he is now.
-That's like --
I mean, he is now, yeah.
-Now he's part of the world.
Now he's into the world.
-Now he's part of
the Emily universe.
-Now he has to make a cameo.
-By the way, I'm like,
"How can we make that happen?"
-Yeah, done. He's watching.
-I mean, Peyton,
if you're watching...
-Yeah, let's take care of this.
I want to say,
you just had a huge weekend.
"Windfall"
just came out on Netflix.
[ Cheers and applause ]
People have seen it already.
-Thank you.
-When I watched it again,
it was the number-4 trending
movie on Netflix.
I go, "Man, you're just owning
Netflix right now."
That's great, but --
-Very different than
"Emily," though.
-Very, very different.
Ooh, it's creepy and good.
I loved the whole idea of it.
-Thank you.
-But for this one --
It was also released on Fri--
last Friday,
which was your birthday.
-It was, yeah.
And that was unplanned.
-That's a birthday present
for you.
-It was.
It was really special
birthday gift.
I actually just kept thinking of
it as, like, "Windfall" day.
You have a birthday every year,
but "Windfall" is only one day.
You know, it only comes out
once a year.
It was, like,
a very special day.
-Talk to me about "Windfall,"
because your
husband directed it, right?
-He did, yeah.
-And you made this during --
Is it during the pandemic?
-During the pandemic, yeah.
Charlie conceptualized it with
his three friends
and writing partners,
and they did it in one location
during the pandemic --
to not reference COVID itself,
but to reference the feeling of
feeling claustrophobic
and stuck in one's environment,
'cause it does take place
in one location
with three, kind of four,
cast members.
And it was all done with
no shutdowns
at the height of the pandemic,
right before "Emily" Season 2.
So it was a real, like,
team effort,
and we're really proud of it.
-I mean, doing all that
and getting married --
-Oh, we were planning
the wedding and shooting
and going off to Paris.
And it was a wild --
-That's bonding right there.
-It was a wild --
It was -- And he's --
Like I said, he's backstage.
It all happened.
-Going strong. Yeah, absolutely.
Who came up with
the idea for this --
-Well, Jason Segel
came up with the initial idea,
but Charlie,
Andrew Kevin Walker,
and Justin Lader,
Charlie's writing partner,
all conceptualized it
on Zoom over the pandemic.
-It is good and scary
and creepy,
but can you explain
the plot for everyone?
-Yeah, the premise is
what happens when
a robbery goes wrong, I guess,
the realistic,
dark-comedic-thriller elements
of what happens when
a robbery goes wrong.
And there's a guy that comes
into a vacation home of
a C.E.O. and his wife
and what ensues after that.
-It's crazy and --
Yeah, of course,
and Jason Segel, of course.
He thought of some -- Yeah.
-And, I mean, Jesse Plemons.
-Jesse Plemons.
-He can do no wrong.
-He really can't.
-And he's, like,
freaking nominated for an Oscar.
I mean, come on.
-Come on.
Yeah, give it up for
Jesse Plemons.
-Yes.
-He is unbelievable.
But every -- You are, too.
-Thank you.
-Everybody is great, and it
goes -- twists and turns,
and next thing you know,
you're like,
"Oh, this is really weird
and it's cool and it's fun."
And then you go...
[ Gasps ]
Okay, now it's like" --
-I get to do some fun stuff.
-Yeah.
No spoilers,
but, yeah, you really do.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Lily Collins in
"Windfall."
Take a look at this.
-All three of us -- we have to
find a way through this.
So it comes down to
how much and how soon.
So, how much?
-To what?
To disappear
and start a new life?
It looks like that's what
it's going to take, so,
you know...$150,000.
What?
-150,000?
-150,000.
-You think that's enough?
-Yeah, I think you're probably
gonna want more than that.
-If you are looking for
any reasonable quality of life,
yes, that's right.
-You know what?
Something tells me that maybe
you and I have some
very different pictures
of quality of life.
-Yeah! Lily Collins!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Windfall" is
streaming now on Netflix.